[Music]
[Applause]
mr. president as faculty marshal I have
the honor to declare the one hundred and
twentieth commencement of Carnegie
Mellon University as authorized by the
trustees to be in session
[Applause]
[Music]
please rise for the singing of our
national anthem by the local performance
class of 2017
[Music]
[Applause]
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
good morning we are gathered in a
wonderful place of collaborative study
work and living please be seated
[Music]
[Applause]
together all of us we are diverse in our
fields of study our talents and our
abilities our ethnicities and the places
that we call home
in light of a respect for others and
with an acknowledgement of our
differences I invite you to join me if
you aren't able in a moment of silence
as we quiet our hearts and prayer in a
posture of thankfulness for this day and
for the class of 2017 Almighty God we
gather today to celebrate the diligent
work and the dedication of the Carnegie
Mellon University class of 2017 we pause
for a moment to give thanks for those
who have helped these students achieve
this day for the parents family friends
teachers and any others who have been
their providers of support throughout
the years we choose this day to be
grateful for the vision and direction of
those who helped make Carnegie Mellon
the institution it is today we give
thanks to the leadership and
administration who continue to carry on
the vision of having a transformative
impact on society through continual
innovation in education research
creativity and entrepreneurship continue
to teach these students and us as well
to look with compassion on others take
away any arrogance or hatred
they may impact our view of others give
us the Grace and ability to love our
neighbors and to seek justice and peace
in all areas of life
bless the students as they enter the
next stages of their lives and seek to
reach their full potential be with them
as they take steps into the known and
into the unknown may all that they do
and the decisions that they make honor
you and the tradition of Carnegie Mellon
University we send them forth to impact
Society in transformative ways through
their work through their lives and their
partnerships be with us this day and let
these students bring you glory our heart
is in the work all men
[Applause]
morning everyone it's a good day for the
graduates whoo on behalf of the Board of
Trustees let me welcome you to the 120th
commencement of Carnegie Mellon
University my name is Jim Rohr and it's
my honor and pleasure to serve as the
board chairman for the 2017 Carnegie
Mellon commencement to all the students
who are graduating today let me begin by
congratulating you when your achievement
this degree represents years of hard
work and self-discipline of discovery
and creativity and problem-solving I
hope it has a little fun included as
well at Carnegie Mellon the degree is a
sign that you have surpassed a high
standard of accomplishment in science
art and ideas and we are ready to use
this knowledge in your lives and your
future professions you are ready to take
on the charge of continuing the
longstanding tradition of doing the work
that matters congratulations to you all
we also like the wish congratulations to
the family members and to the friends
mentors faculty and staff who also take
great pride in what the graduates have
accomplished graduation from a demanding
academic institution like Carnegie
Mellon is a team effort
these students couldn't have done it
without you so I invite all of us to
thank the support team with a wonderful
round of applause for the support with
us today and our 120th commencement are
some faculty and students from Carnegie
Mellon's other locations around the
world I am particularly pleased to
welcome students from the CMU Silicon
Valley campus and all the way for Rwanda
and our CMU Africa program and also our
first - Lakshmi
subramanian CMU's Africa student
excellent award scholars we are
delighted to have you here with us today
as members of the Carnegie Mellon
community your ambassadors of our
distinguished distinctive University it
was at carnegie mellon that you gave
solid grounding in your major field and
it was at carnegie mellon that you
collaborated with people whose
backgrounds were very different from
your own and it was at carnegie mellon
that you discovered new ideas about the
world and actually new aspects about
yourselves as trustees it is our job to
uphold the university's values and help
CMU achieve further excellence in
fulfillment of those values many
trustees are here on the platform this
morning and I would like them to stand
and be recognized
trustees
this year
Carnegie Mellon has added to its
impressive momentum with a number of new
initiatives and partnerships that are
contributing to the growth of knowledge
in the world and we're moving forward
rapidly with distinctive and
collaborative education ambitious
research programs in areas ranging from
energy data science workings of the
brain and even the science of learning
the campus footprint is growing with
plans fully underway for spectacular new
spaces designed to make CMU a standard
Center for the 21st century higher
education with emphasis on collaboration
fields across across the enterprise
create a probable problem solving as
well as innovation behind all of this
growth and expansion is our dynamic
president who already - who joined the
university in 2013 from the National
Science Foundation and who has already
had a tremendous effect on this
institution it's my great privilege to
introduce the 9th president of Carnegie
Mellon University dr. subra Suresh
good morning good morning everyone and
congratulations graduates I'm going to
be saying that a few times commencement
is always a special day for family
friends and faculty but more than
anything else it is a milestone for each
of you the graduates the class of 2017
we are here to celebrate your
accomplishments over the past four years
or five years if you are from the School
of Architecture you worked hard to get
here and we are very proud and honored
to salute you today let me also express
my deep appreciation to the Carnegie
Mellon University Board of Trustees and
to the chairman of the board Jim Rohr
for all their energy vision friendship
and leadership with their health CMU is
poised to have a bright future thank you
Jim and thank you
I would like to also recognize a number
of alumni groups in attendance today the
2017 Distinguished Alumni Award honorees
the class of 1967 50th reunion
celebrants and of course our legacy
families just to give you an idea
yesterday morning when we met with the
class of the 50th reunion class a number
of things had changed a postage stamp
was five cents in 1967 today is 49 cents
and it says forever if you can believe
it Carnegie Mellon's endowment at that
time was 75 million dollars it's much
greater now there are many many more
things that have happened in 67 but the
best news of all is that with every
incoming class the quality and impact of
Carnegie Mellon education has increased
substantially and you represent the very
best of Carnegie Mellon thank you
CMU is a beloved tradition in so many
families and we are also pleased to see
successive generations of family members
attending CMU all CMU alumni here today
are especially that designated by the
blue stools they are wearing we are
happy to see so many of you back here
Woodall CMU Alumni in attendance please
stand and be recognized
[Applause]
it's wonderful to have you here and I
hope our new graduates today continue
this tradition and return to
commencement in the future one alumna
who our new graduate should get to know
is our Alumni Association Board
president
Debbie u Dietrich College class of 1989
Debbie joined the Alumni Association
Board in 2010 and began her term nearly
a year ago while she was earning her
bachelor's degree in technical writing
at Carnegie Mellon she was a reporter
for the Tartan and was active in the
pre-law Society now a partner at the
firm of Gallagher Sharpe in Cleveland
Ohio debbie has been an active volunteer
for the Northeast Ohio alumni network
since 2007 having served previously as
network president she also volunteers as
a Carnegie Mellon admission interviewer
and is active in a number of
professional and community organizations
and since taking office
she's been an outstanding representative
of all Carnegie Mellon alumni I would
like to invite Debbie now to the podium
Debbie
Thank You president Suresh and
congratulations to the class of 2017 and
welcome to the Carnegie Mellon Alumni
family as you begin the next chapter of
your life please remember that you are
now lifelong members of the Carnegie
Mellon community therefore where your
Carnegie Mellon clothing bring your CMU
much to work and be proud to be part of
such an amazing group although Carnegie
Mellon alone make up only a small
percentage of the world's population our
contributions are great in our impact
enormous we just celebrated the
achievement and service of a few of our
dedicated and talented alums at the
alumni awards ceremony on Friday and I
was inspired not only by their
achievement but by their incredible
passion for Carnegie Mellon even 60
years after graduation no matter where
your life has will take you you will
find Carnegie Mellon alums in over 149
countries around the world
we're leaving communities companies and
industries and we are making the world a
better place although you are leaving
the comforts of your Carnegie Mellon
home remember to always stay true to
yourself continue to be intellectually
curious and continue to learn be
supportive of each other as well as for
those who are following in your
footsteps and always go outside of your
comfort zone and embrace your vision for
the future the Carnegie Mellon Alumni
Association provides many ways for you
to continue to learn and to connect with
each other and with a university in
addition to virtual programs we have
over 55 active alumni networks around
the world therefore as you settle into
your new lives please find your local
alumni network and get involved and as
with any family I wish that you will
come back to visit often stay in touch
and think of us we wish you nothing but
the best and brightest future
on behalf of the Carnegie Mellon Alumni
Association and board it is my distinct
pleasure to welcome you into the
Carnegie Mellon Alumni family
congratulations class of 2017
thank you very much Debbie our student
speaker today is one of 129 students
from 30 countries and 75 universities
chosen this academic year as a
schwartzman scholar today Krystal Thomas
earned her bachelor's degree in
biological sciences from Carnegie Mellon
University's Mellon College of Science
crystal has been an active member of the
Carnegie Mellon community serving as
founding president of colors at CMU a
student organization that promotes open
conversations on race and diversity she
served as one of the inaugural members
of the diversity and inclusion
roundtable and is a mentor in the
coaching minority progress and success
in science program she is a past
president of the Gates Millennium
Scholarship from the Bill and Melinda
Gates Foundation and is an Andrew
Carnegie Society college scholar a
distinction bestowed upon only 40
graduating seniors the daughter of a
Haitian immigrants Krystle plans to
complete a master of global affairs with
a concentration in public policy at
Tsinghua University in Beijing China and
work to address barriers to healthcare
faced by immigrant families it was a
great pleasure for me this morning to
meet crystals parents crystal I would
like to now invite you to the 40
everyone five years ago I came to CMU as
a high school student I was here for the
university's summer academy of math and
science or Sam's for short now I didn't
know the Carnegie Mellon or that Sam's
excuse me or the program for minority
students and the entire time I was
surrounded by people who look like me so
I left thinking this is great
Carnegie Mellon University a
historically black college for math and
science right I'm Paula going here even
though CMU wasn't exactly what I
expected I'm still so glad I decided to
come here I have learned so much or here
at Carnegie Mellon and not just
academically problem-solving had a whole
difficult conversations and most
importantly I now know there's so so
much more that I don't know what drives
people how do our environments influence
us how is our world interconnected I
started to think about these questions
because I've been fortunate enough to
meet many of you and getting to know
your stories your perspective and the
way you think about things I didn't
phone away
as someone who came from a town for high
school students but they couldn't go to
college if they didn't have the money as
someone whose pediatrician told her at
least one of us made out of this
worthless place as someone whose
relative told her
is it Carnegie Mellon a bit too advanced
for you I am immensely proud to be a
part of this campus I am so proud to be
able to offer you today what now we're
about to leave the CMU bubble some of us
may start working and receive nice
paychecks some of us may go on to
graduate school and receive alright
paychecks and some of us may take a
well-deserved break but what's been
instead of thinking about the next
achievement now is our opportunity to
reflect on purpose as we enter the next
stage of our life purpose the reason we
exist may be Carnegie Mellon has already
helped you find your purpose maybe
you're just getting started we should
reflect on purpose because it develops
us keeps us resilient and can lead us to
happiness so how do we crystallize
purpose or even find purpose in the
first place we help others we are driven
by the need to impact others we're
social animals after all I'm a biology
major trust me
so what's the relationship between
purpose helping others and Happiness
well to me there are three levels of
happiness first you can gain happiness
from simply building something then
there's the second level of happiness
when people praise what you have built
and as if there's the third level of
happiness when someone tells you what
you have built has changed my life that
level of happiness just can't be beat in
the past that makes you feel the most
fulfilled the past that gives you the
greatest happiness can give you insight
on purpose we've already been practicing
impacting the lives of others we've
overloaded become execs on board
volunteered for a thousand plus tutor
taa research strives because CMU is a
striving place we're a bunch of
overachievers who've been presented with
so many opportunities and have been
encouraged to learn now is our time to
put practice into action
continue to strive continue to aspire
and as you leave here today send your
life around purpose turn your life
around
impacting others but purpose guide you
and to everyone who helped us along the
way
mentors who have guided us throughout
the process
faculty members who helped to see just
what we could do and loved ones who have
been with us and encouraged us every
step of the way thank you
and thank you class of 2017 I know you
will do great things
thank you
Thank You crystal now we come to the
presentation of special doctors degrees
awarded to honor individuals who have
had extraordinary impact in areas that
reflect Carnegie Mellon's trends in the
arts sciences scholarship and society
recipients of these honorary degrees
have in common and notable record of a
college even
in their chosen fields and they each
have made in their own domains
substantial contributions to the
advancement of knowledge the enrichment
of the arts and culture and to bettering
the well-being of humanity Provost
forums again ian will present each
candidate and cite the achievements that
Merrick this honor
then all candidates will together
receive their degrees and their doctoral
hoods Farnum
good morning class of 2017 oh no you
don't understand this is a celebration
we're going to try this again good
morning class of 2017 much better let me
add my warm welcome to all of you and
extend my congratulations to the class
of 2017 we'll mahzarin banaji please
come forward
mahzarin banaji you are one of the most
profound experimental psychologists in
the world co-author of blind spot hidden
biases of good people you're highly
celebrated for your study of the
disparity between conscious expression
of attitudes and beliefs and our less
conspicuous implicit behavior you have
been the recipient of numerous accolades
for your work as a social scientist
professor and senior advisor at Harvard
University a fellow of the American
Academy of Arts and Sciences you receive
the 2017 American Psychological
associations distinguished scientific
contribution award in 2016 you garnered
the Association for psychological
sciences William James fellow award for
lifetime of significant intellectual
contribution to the basic science of
psychology and in 2015 you were elected
a fellow of British Academy mahzarin
banaji for your preeminent contribution
to psychology and higher education
Carnegie Mellon is proud to award you
the honorary Doctor of Science and
Technology
[Applause]
we'll Vivian Davidson Hewitt please come
forward
vivianne davidson hewitt as a CMU alumni
you have brought honor and acclaim to
this university throughout the history
throughout your history-making career
shortly after earning your bachelor's
degree in 1944
yes 1944 you became the first
african-american librarian at carnegie
library of pittsburgh then went on to
become the first black president of the
special Libraries Association and the
first african-american chief librarian
for the Rockefeller Foundation the
Carnegie Endowment for international
peace and the Council on Foreign
Relations an inductee of the special
Library Association's Hall of Fame you
were also sanctioned a dame by queen
elizabeth ii for your many years of
dedication to the Order of Saint John
while living in New York your love for
artistic expression Liz you and your
husband to start a collection of Haitian
and african-american art today the
Hewitt collection is recognized as one
of the finest collections of its kind in
the world
Vivian Davidson do it for your epic
contributions to library science and the
arts Carnegie Mellon is honored to award
you the honorary Doctor of Humane
Letters will Michael Keaton Douglas
please come forward Michael Keaton
Douglas your extraordinary acting talent
has brought you continuous critical and
public acclaim for decades your
outstanding leading performances in two
films in 1988 Beetlejuice now you can
cheer and clean and sober earned you two
best Academy Awards from the National
Society of Film Critics your portrayal
of the iconic superhero in the
blockbuster films Batman
and that man returns
has been entertaining audiences for
generations and you have been honored
for numerous awards for your roles in
birdman and spotlight both of which won
the Academy Award for Best Picture
you're passionate mentorship to students
as a visiting scholar in CMU's
entertainment Technology Center is
helping to shape the future of
entertainment industry Michael Keaton
Douglas for your extraordinary
commitment and contribution to the
entertainment industry Carnegie Mellon
is pleased to award you the honorary
degree of the Doctor of Fine Arts
[Applause]
we'll Bernard Osher please come forward
Bernard Osher you have worked tirelessly
since 1977 to improve quality of life
through your support of higher education
and the arts your generous philanthropy
over many of those years has affected
countless organizations your business
acumen rooted in your family's hardware
and plumbing supply store led you to
become a founding director of the second
largest saving institutions in the
United States a renowned art collector
you purchased the auction house of
Butterfield and Butterfield and oversaw
its growth to become the fourth largest
auction house in the world your support
of Osher Lifelong Learning Institute
including ours here at Carnegie Mellon
University which is by the way
celebrating its 25th year anniversary
allows older adults to extend their
education on University and college
campuses all around the country Bernard
Osher for your unwavering service and
commitment to education and the arts
Carnegie Mellon is honored to award you
the honorary degree of Doctor of Fine
Arts
we'll make whitman please come forward
[Applause]
meg whitman your exceptional leadership
knowledge and business acumen place you
among the most respected and powerful
women in the world today your stellar
record of achievement is well documented
at Hewlett Packard company
you lit an historic resurgence by
creating two Fortune 100 technology
firms Beulah Packard Enterprise which
you currently lead as president and CEO
and HP Inc for which you serve as
chairman of the board
you also have held executive roles with
Hasbro FTD and Walt Disney Company and
your leadership at eBay led to a truly
remarkable expansion under your
direction the e-commerce company grew
from 30 employees and 4 million in
annual revenue to more than 15,000
employees and 8 billion in annual
revenue
your elite stature in the business
community serves as a role model for
women in leadership positions in every
field in every country meg Whitman for
just your distinguished contributions to
global business your superior leadership
abilities and your inspiration to future
leaders across the globe Carnegie Mellon
is pleased to award you the honorary
degree of Doctor of business practice
mahzarin banaji Vivienne Davidson Hewitt
Michael Keaton Bernard Osher and Meg
Whitman by virtue of the authority
granted to me by the Board of Trustees I
hereby confer these honorary degrees
upon you with all the rights honors
privileges and responsibilities
pertaining thereto congratulations
[Applause]
business leaders political activists
philanthropist these are all
descriptions of meg Whitman one of the
most successful business executives in
the world today since 2011
she's been president CEO and our
chairman of hewlett-packard and since
2015 she's been the CEO and president of
Hewlett Packard Enterprise and chairman
of Hewlett Packard is chairman of HP Inc
Board of Directors as someone who knows
her from serving on that board at HP Inc
I can tell you no one just shows up and
becomes president CEO and chairman one
of the world's most important
corporations in a business world
overwhelmingly run by men Meg Whitman
has earned every accolade and has
repeatedly demonstrated the benefit of
pursuing new and unexpected challenges
having been an accomplished high school
student athlete Meg set her sights on
becoming a physician when she enrolled
at Princeton just a few years after
women were first admitted but a summer
spent selling magazine advertising
reveals magazine advertising reveals her
true calling this drove her to pursue
her bachelor's degree in economics and
then an MBA from Harvard med Spath from
there is meteoric she joined Procter &
Gamble where she worked with Steve Case
who later founded AOL she took a
position with Bain & Company where she
rose to senior vice president and along
the way worked with Mitt Romney who
would later become governor of
Massachusetts and compete for the
presidency of the United States
mengdan served as an executive with
Disney stride right FTD and Hasbro
before taking the helm of a fledgling
company that made her a household name
auction web is probably not the name you
are expecting but under 10 years of her
leadership meg Whitman grew auction web
into a multi-billion dollar global
phenomenon now known as eBay that has
revolutionized the way humanity trades
goods not content to rest on our laurels
make started a charitable foundation
that has focused much of its giving and
addressing global warming and ecosystem
restoration
she's also dabbled in politics running
an historic campaign for governor of
California in 2010 in fact the New York
Times singled her out as one of the
women most likely to become the first
female president of the United States
since 2011 Megas worked tirelessly at
Hewlett Packard company and Hewlett
Packard Enterprise after their historic
split in 2015 I give you the person
Forbes magazine named the 20th most
powerful woman in the world Meg Whitman
well president sure ash members of the
class of 2017 members of the faculty
distinguished guests fellow recipients
of honorary degrees families of the
graduating class ladies and gentlemen
it's a true honor to be with you today
and it's a great privilege to receive an
honorary Doctor of business practice
degree and I am grateful to be earning
my degree in a lot less time and with a
lot fewer all-nighters than it took many
of you to earn yours to the parents of
the graduating class of 2017 it is a
magnificent and memorable day when your
child graduates from college it
certainly is a wonderful day for you and
I'm guessing that for many of you
parents it's a pretty good day for your
wallets as well
congratulations for having traveled this
journey with your children a journey
that began not with their enrollment at
this university but at the moment of
their birth whether your children fully
realizes or not whether they have fully
expressed it to you or not and they will
they would not be here today without
your love and support and encouragement
along the way so congratulations to the
parents
most important to the class of 2017
congratulations
graduating from college is an impressive
achievement but especially graduating
from one of the leading universities in
the world an institution characterized
by high standards and excellence one
that has produced winners of Nobel
Prizes and Turing Tony Emmy and Academy
Award winners Carnegie Mellon mellon
university has prepared you for a life
of purpose and meeting and there are
people and moments you will never forget
including I understand the Spring
Carnival which includes what I gather
are some pretty amazing amusement park
rides booths and buggy races to
bagpiping which the school has made into
an artform and to my personal favorite
the band without pants a tradition
unique to Carnegie Mellon and I'm
confident I can say one you are unlikely
to encounter in your first full-time job
you are graduating at a moment of great
challenge for our nation when our
country will decide on matters having to
do not with just Commerce but conscience
not just what we will with what we will
gain but what we will give not just with
our military power but with our deepest
ideals this is hardly the most difficult
moment in American history
I believe you can safely argue that the
Civil War two world wars and the Great
Depression have us beat by a longshot
you are a blessed generation in so many
ways with opportunities unimaginable to
past generations and gratitude is one of
the hallmarks of a fulfilled life but
every life has hardships every
generation faces obstacles and we are in
the midst of our profoundly in poor
moment in the political and civil civic
life of America the challenges today are
more from within than without and I
believe this is a moment that if we do
not handle it well could produce harmful
effects on my generation and on yours
and on generations yet on board the
stakes are that serious so today I want
to speak about some disturbing trends in
our national life trends that need to be
challenged by people of both genders
every class race and ethnic ethnic
background of every political party and
ideology but most especially by young
people who are not only inheritors of
the future but will do so much to shape
it
the first disturbing trend I want to
mention is the attack on truth there are
many people these days including people
at the highest level in public life
who use lies lies to de-fat devalue
truth those who are part of this effort
like describing what's happening
euphemistically using phrases like
alternative facts but we know better
to paraphrase Shakespeare to clarify
Shakespeare's Juliet a lie by any other
name is still a lie what is so striking
is the brazenness and rapidity of the
lies and their purpose which is to D
legitimate information hostile to those
in power the lies tumbled down like rock
in an avalanche they are not subtle
they are overt obvious and part of a
conscious effort language is being
employed not to reveal reality but to
obscure it not to simply mislead people
but to disorient them to assert power
over truth in an effort to deconstruct
it so here's why this should matter to
you if we do not share a common reality
we can't reason together truth creates
restraints on power if we allow those
with power to control the very idea of
truth itself then we cannot identify and
stand against injustice and if we can't
identify injustice then we cannot
replace it with concepts like equality
under law respect decency compassion and
justice itself
a great university is always enlisted
against the spread of illusion and on
the side of reality said President
Kennedy and that is the essence of your
calling as graduates of a great
University my encouragement to you is to
be women and men who stand for truth who
spend your life in search of it even if
you never fully know it who believed in
inquiry in fact in objective reality and
who have the courage to speak truth to
power even when there may be a cost to
doing so if you do if you are defenders
of truth and an age marked by lies it
will have a liberating effect on our
fellow citizens and make more possible
all good things in life
a second truth that needs to be
confronted is the attack on free speech
in the last several years we have seen a
powerful movement one that seeks to shut
down free speech gained traction in the
Academy the very institutions that were
created in order to allow for the free
exchange of ideas on some campuses we've
seen certain speakers not invited on
others they've been shouted down and on
still others we are witnessing violence
now I understand this kind of thing
isn't happening on most American
campuses but it's happening in too many
places and it needs to end but there's
something else going on as well
college students are increasingly
demanding protection from words and
speech they find offensive we hear a lot
about trigger warnings and safe spaces
which are designed to protect students
from viewpoints that they might find
upsetting and unsettling here's why I
think this is problematic for one thing
I don't think most of you want to be
treated like porcelain dolls and now
that you are college graduates the rest
of the world and
certainly the business world won't treat
you that way so no one is doing college
students any favors when they
intellectually isolate
but the issue extends beyond the walls
of the Academy and matters whether or
not you ever step foot on a campus again
for while many of you are about to
complete your formal education you will
spend a lifetime continuing to learn
gathering and processing new information
and dealing with people with different
life experiences and points of view
shutting down free feet insulating
ourselves from hearing competing points
of view is the equivalent of injecting
poison into the bloodstream of our
Republic John Stuart Mill in his 1859
classic on Liberty put it as well as
anyone ever has and I quote he who knows
only his own side of the case knows
little of that Mill wrote his reason may
be good and no one may have been able to
refute them but he is equally unable to
refute the reasons on the opposite side
if he does not so much as know what they
are
he has no ground for preferring either
opinion mill went on to say this nor is
it enough that he should hear the
opinions of adversaries from his own
teachers presented as they state them
and accompanied by what they offer as
reputations he must be able to hear from
persons who actually believe them he
must know them in their most plausible
and persuasive form so my encouragement
to you is to be the men and women who
stand up for free speech who welcomes
debate who model for others what genuine
dialogue is and who are not afraid to
have your beliefs challenged too many of
us live in intellectual silos where we
seek out people and information that
simply reinforces our existing opinions
venture out of those silos we are better
when we are exposed to different ideas
and competing philosophies learn to
listen in order to understand others not
just to respond to them and remain open
to the possibility that you may may have
something to learn from others be the
generation that embodies real tolerance
genuine inquiry and authentic
open-mindedness it is what this nation
desperately needs during this fractured
and fractious time the third trend that
needs to be confronted is the attack on
civility we live in an age of escalating
incivility we see it all around us on
our roads in airwaves in sports stadiums
and on social media and in politics the
problem has gotten worse recently with
those running for high public office
mocking reporters and demeaning
opponents with childish names or worse
it seems that no words no matter how
hurtful or cruel to others are
considered inappropriate we are
fostering the conditions in which we
view others not as opponents but enemies
we're treating one another as subhuman
and that's a terribly dangerous line to
cross civility is more than nice manners
it's a precondition of democratic
dialogue in the words of Professor
Stephen L Carter of Yale Law School
civility is part of the quote etiquette
of democracy unquote it allows for
genuine social interaction it's been
said that the true genius of Martin
Luther King jr. was not his ability to
argue the pain of an oppressed people
but his ability to inspire those very
people to be loving and civil in their
dissent we should treat each other with
civility not
because we agree with others but because
it is a measure of our respect for human
dignity it's what we owe all people
including those with whom we have fierce
disagreements our institutions our
culture our communities cannot be
sustained let alone thrive if civility
is eroded it is an essential democratic
virtue Kingman Brewster a former
president of Yale said quote the
presumption of innocence is not just a
legal concept in commonplace terms it
rests on the generosity of spirit which
assumes the best not the worst of a
stranger so my encouragement to you is
to be the women and men who embody
civility who demonstrate a generosity of
spirit in an ungenerous time and who
assume the best not the worst of the
stranger of those you do not know people
whose life experiences are different
than yours
and who may see the world in a
dramatically different way than you do
in doing so you will make us a more
decent and just society this country
desperately needs the skills you have
developed during your years at Carnegie
Mellon but it needs something more than
your skills it needs your ideals you
leave this great University as better
men and women than when you arrived more
knowledgeable and better educated I'm
sure but I trust wiser and more hopeful
there's a beautiful line by William
Wordsworth in his poem the prelude in
which he says quote what we have loved
others will love and we will teach them
how the faculty at CMU has taught you
what to know and love and now it is your
turn to teach others what you have come
to know and love I wish you all a joy a
life of joy
and purpose of success and fulfillment
and congratulations to the great class
of 2017 thank you very much meg thank
you for your thoughtful and sobering
remarks you're not only we're not only
inspired by your words but also
motivated by your example it's been an
honor to have you as our keynote speaker
thank you again meg please join me once
again in thanking magna
it is now my pleasure to recognize the
faculty members who have recently
accepted emeritus status like all of our
educators these distinguished
individuals are scholars scientists
artists and above all teachers they have
left an in-depth indelible in the work
more on this University through the
support and encouragement they have
provided to our students and through
their legacy of exceptional scholarship
the names of all retiring faculty will
be projected on the screen at this time
those retiring faculty who are present
this morning please stand as I read your
name please hold your applause until I
have read all their names mark pitchmen
associate professor of organizational
behavior and theory temporary School of
Business Peggy Ann now professor of
English Dietrich College of Humanities
and Social Sciences
Kenneth kotovsky professor of psychology
Dietrich College of Humanities and
Social Sciences
Gregory Lehane professor of drama and
music College of Fine Arts Mel Segal
associate research professor school of
computer science please join me in
thanking all of Carnegie Mellon's
emeritus faculty for their service and
dedication to the University
I would now like to recognize those
faculty members who were recently
honored with the title of University
Professors being appointed a university
professor is one of the highest honors
that a faculty member can receive at
carnegie mellon receiving this rank
confers both honor and obligation on to
its recipients and denotes a legacy of
exceptional contribution to education
artistic creativity and/or research this
prestigious group includes faculty from
all of our colleges and schools I am
pleased to announce that three faculty
members have joined these distinguished
ranks this year nominated and
recommended by academic leaders and
university professors and promoted to
university professor by presidents
irrationally as I read your name please
stand and be recognized the first newly
appointed University professor is Marti
Gaynor EJ Barone professor of economics
and health policy Heinz College
I'm also pleased to congratulate Susan
sue professor of design College of Fine
Arts the third newly appointed
University professor could not be here
today but I like to congratulate
congratulate him
Alan Freese professor of mathematical
sciences Mellon College of Science we
will now begin the formal conferral of
degrees on all students who have duly
completed the requirements of their
programs to the satisfaction and
approval of their faculty members you
can clap this okay the commencement
program gives each student's degree an
area of study which will be called out
and celebrated at departmental diploma
ceremonies I encourage families and
friends to look and listen beyond just
your own graduates listing to get a
sense of the unique educational
environment at Carnegie Mellon the
environment that makes this institution
so distinctive and this graduating class
so exceptional I wish to begin by
acknowledging the achievements of this
year's group of doctoral candidates
these outstanding scholars received
their academic hoods at a special
ceremony yesterday afternoon in earning
their doctorates they have made a
commitment to a life of scholarly
pursuits and have reaffirmed the
importance and prominence of Carnegie
Mellon as one of the nation's premier
research and universities I would invite
the doctors candidates to please rise
and be recognized
doctors candidates
they were about 300 of em yesterday
afternoon that party must have lasted
really really late last night please be
seated there are some of them back there
as well thank you
in addition we're pleased to officially
confirm a charter degrees to students
graduating from Carnegie Mellon
University Kotter campus these students
earn degrees from the d3 College the
Mellon College of Science the School of
Computer Science and a temper Business
School at this time I want to recognize
the Dean of Carnegie Mellon University
at cutter Dean Ilford Baybars who has
been an exemplary reader of campus in
Doha and who just completed his last
academic year as Dean for the past six
years bill fir has led the CMU Q campus
with honor and distinction enhancing the
CMU experience through his passion for
teaching and collaboration and his
dedication to students once a successor
is named Alfred will resume his duties
as Gerald Leland Bach professor of
operations management in temporary
School of Business where he has been a
member of our faculty since 1978 the
inve bars thank you for your service and
please stand to be recognized
[Applause]
candidates I'm going to give you some
directions on what to do next
class of 2017 are you ready okay we'll
try again class of 2017 are you ready we
will ask each degree candidates from
each college to stand and be recognized
as you're called upon by your Dean when
all schools and colleges have been
recognized the president then asked all
students to stand again at which time he
will formally confer your degrees and
don't be shy last year we had a bit of a
competition for the most boisterous
school or college so let's hear your
enthusiasm as your Dean calls on you
that's an open invitation are you with
me if not just follow the person next to
you for the conferral of degrees at the
university level when we call for degree
candidates to stand we will be calling
for broad categories of bachelor's
master's or doctoral level candidates I
will now call on the Dean of each school
or college to present its candidate
president Suresh please join me at the
podium
to begin I wish to recognize James
Garrett Dean of the College of
Engineering
this is when the fun begins making lots
of noise will all the candidates from
the College of Engineering please ride
[Applause]
mr. president upon the recommendation of
our faculty I have the honor of
presenting the bachelor's master's and
doctoral degree candidates from the
College of Engineering will the new
College of Engineering graduates please
be seated and be quiet thank you
Dan Martin the Dean of the College of
Fine Arts could not be here today due to
illness we wish him a speedy recovery to
present the candidates from the College
of Fine Arts on Dan's behalf I now
recognize Eric Anderson associate dean
Eric
[Applause]
representing with even greater
enthusiasm with all the candidates from
the College of Fine Arts please rise
[Applause]
mr. president upon the recommendation of
our faculty I have the honor of
representing the bachelor's master's and
doctoral degree candidates from the
College of Fine Arts well the new
College of Fine Arts graduates graduates
please be seated I now recognize the
Dean of the Dietrich College of
Humanities and Social Sciences richard
china
will all the candidates from the
Dietrich College of Humanities and
Social Sciences please show these other
students what enthusiasm actually sounds
like and do so as you rise
mr. president upon the recommendation of
our faculty I have the honor of
presenting the bachelor's master's and
doctoral degree candidates from the
Dietrich College of Humanities and
Social Sciences great job now you can
sit down I now recognize the Dean of the
Heinz College
Ramaiah Krishna will will all the
candidates from the Heinz College please
rise
[Applause]
[Music]
but that's a good demonstration you need
no prompting from me with the president
upon the recommendation of our faculty I
have the honor of presenting the
master's and doctoral campus
degree candidates from the Heinz College
the new Heinz College graduates please
be seated
I now call on the Dean of the school of
the Mellon College of Science Rebecca
doors being as you know the indoors has
just completed her first year as the
Dean of MCS coming to us from Purdue
University where she let their
statistics department we are delighted
to congratulate her on her first ever
CMU c'mon
alright don't disappoint me will the
2017 melech Mellon College of Science
candidates please rise and help Krystal
[Applause]
okay mr. president upon the
recommendation of our distinguished
faculty I have the distinct honor of
presenting the bachelors masters and
doctoral degree candidates from the
Mellon College of Science well the new
Mellon College of Science graduates
please be seated
I now call on the Dean of the school of
computer science and her more
[Applause]
okay
will the scarily awesome
candidates from the School of Computer
Science please accomplish a decibel
level of zero 6f
[Applause]
mr. president upon the recommendation of
our faculty I have the honor of
presenting the bachelor's master's and
doctoral degree candidates from the
school of computer science
okay well the new school of computer
science graduates please be seated I now
call on the Dean of The Temper School of
Business
Robert Daymond you heard the challenge
will all the candidates from the small
but mighty Temper School of Business
please rise
[Applause]
Thank You mr. president upon the
recommendation of our faculty I have the
honor of presenting that bachelor's
master's and doctoral degree candidates
from The Temper School of Business will
a new temper school graduates please be
seated
Carnegie Mellon is proud to lead the
world in interdisciplinary research and
education and nurtures several
university-wide inter-college
and joint degree programs within our
University on behalf of all the deans
and program directors I will now present
the candidates for degrees from these
special programs with all the bachelor's
master's and doctoral candidates in our
interdisciplinary programs please rise
with the president upon the
recommendation of our faculty I have the
honor of presenting these candidates
from our university-wide inter college
and joint degree programs
I will ask these students remain
standing and I would like to invite
students from all other key colleges and
schools to stand once again for the
official conferral of degrees by
president suresh by virtue of the
authority granted to me by the Board of
Trustees I hereby confer these degrees
upon these candidates with all the
rights honors privileges and
responsibilities pertaining thereto
I'm pleased to join the deans and the
Faculty of the entire University in
congratulating you congratulations class
of 2017
with all the new bachelor's master's and
doctoral graduates and the new Alumni
Association members of Carnegie Mellon
University
please be seated I am immensely proud to
stand before you the Carnegie Mellon
University graduating class of 2017 in
my charge to you the graduates I wish to
focus on two themes the number four
especially focusing on the last four
years of your presence here and some
thoughts and suggestions for your career
and life beyond Carnegie Mellon
University four years that's an
interesting interval of time every four
years we see a US presidential election
Olympic Games a Soccer World Cup and of
course a leap year four years ago in the
summer of 2013 you arrived on this
campus as freshman accompanied by your
family members I had the enormous
privilege and honor of welcoming you to
CMU at the orientation event on the mall
I told you in your parents at that time
that like you I had just arrived on
campus as a freshman to begin the
journey with you how many of you
remember that
[Music]
[Applause]
in the succeeding four years you have
accomplished much in your learning your
field of specialization in your personal
growth in your teamwork and in your
global perspectives
you have built valuable relationships
with your mentors and advisors staff
across campus faculty members department
gets Dean's coaches alumni and trustees
you've also contributed so much to the
fabric of this university and its rich
heritage as you walk the corridors of
various buildings plane take the friends
throat the cut push the buggy at
carnival or exhibited your enormous
creativity and technological prowess in
formal classroom work in theatre music
and art in research in poetry and in
presentations you've produced and
exhibited on campus your determination
to improve the human condition and your
compassion and humanity came through the
numerous community service activities
you initiated and executed locally and
around the world my wife Mary and I were
privileged to host many of you on
hundreds of occasions on campus and at
our residence
our for conversations entertainment
meals and social interactions and we
came to see you not just as students but
as members of our family we celebrated
major achievements together and we came
together to hold and support one another
during times of deep sorrow and tragedy
while our faculty continue to garner
international recognition for the
research and creativity you our
graduates today have also accomplished
much in these four years excelling in
athletics creating artificial
intelligence programs that defeated four
of the world's best professional poker
players in a marathon twenty
a poker competition winning the Putnam
competition the premier mathematics
competition for undergraduate students
in North America competing against the
best undergraduate math students in the
country during your time here your
accomplishments helped the university
scale new heights thanks to the
generosity of about 450 donors and the
efforts of many members of the CMU
community the last 40 years saw an
historic buildup of dedicated endowment
to support students through presidential
fellowships and scholarships this
program just established three years ago
has grown to benefit a total of 255
students this year in every college in
school at Carnegie Mellon similar
efforts were created to support faculty
through endowed professorships your
ideas and exuberant engagement helped
the university establish an historic
expansion of the campus to benefit
generations of students in teaching
learning and research all this was
fuelled by one of the most sustained and
successful fundraising efforts in a
continuous four-year period the
university has witnessed this happen as
the university's visibility expanded
around the world from pioneering
university participation at the Tony
Awards on Broadway to faculty engagement
at the World Economic Forum in Davos to
hosting the President of the United
States on our campus and to attracting
several large multinational companies to
Pittsburgh while at the same time we
nurtured and supported our activities at
CMU campuses around the world.you our
work at the university community also
brought to the fore the critical need to
enhance the CMU experience for all this
commitment has already produced
initiatives and action plans for the
next several years to improve programs
and infrastructure for counseling
mentoring and enhancing student support
and services we have accomplished all
this together
in close partnerships with faculty and
staff parents families friends coaches
trustees and alumni today we forced to
reflect and celebrate as well as
recognize and express our pride in what
you have accomplished in your 40 years
and today I challenge you it again what
will you do in the next four years as
you go out into the world in whatever
you do as a Carnegie Mellon graduate you
have joined over 100,000 living alumni
we know that you will be enormous ly
successful and impactful if history is
any indication many of you will occupy
leadership roles where your principles
and values will determine the scale of
your impact if you are a change agent
your world will be changing even faster
than ever before because of the
accelerating pace of change around the
world if you are someone who through
hard work and aspiration tirelessly
seeks to improve status quo it is
imperative that you are hired
adhere to your principles even in the
face of obstacles adversity and setbacks
especially created by those who are
uncomfortable with the disruptions that
emerge from changing the status code
Rosalynn Carter once said a leader takes
people where they want to go a great
leader takes people where they ought to
go even if they do not want to go there
such leaders make great personal
sacrifices to move their organizations
or their countries to a much higher
level against incredible odds and
opposition you may make some mistakes
along the way
but you will learn from it and be a
better person and a better leader never
be hesitant to voice your opinion Sir
Winston Churchill was famously said when
the Eagles are silent
the perixx begin to jabber be an eagle
not a parrot consider the case of
Abraham Lincoln who many historians
consider the greatest president of the
United States Lincoln who led our
country in the middle of the Civil War
established the Morrill land-grant Act
in 1862 that completely transformed the
higher education system of the u.s. his
signing of the Emancipation Proclamation
during a bloody civil war that tolls a
country apart
On January 1 1863 as a presidential
executive order changed our society
forever also in 1863 Lincoln established
the National Academy of Sciences with a
remarkable vision that was free of
political influence
Lincoln faced resistance during his
entire leadership tenure another iconic
leader of our time spent a speech that
captures this theme because of the way
it played out as I read his code try to
guess to whom it is attributed the code
goes like this there will always be
dissident voices expressing opposition
without alternatives finding fault but
never favored perceiving gloom on every
side and seeking influence without
responsibility that was a speech that
President John F Kennedy was supposed to
deliver in Dallas on November 22nd 1963
these words were in his prepared remarks
and he never had a chance to deliver his
speech my charge to you is do the right
thing based on principles values hard
work honesty and integrity as graduates
entering a new world facing new
challenges it is your duty to ensure
that fake use does not overwhelm truth
noise does not drown out the signal
and mere superficial style does not
replace deep substance with a CMU degree
you are well-prepared to separate signal
from noise fact from fiction and
evidence from a mere in window as you
accomplish much we expect you to return
to this campus sharing your knowledge
and experiences whatever you do wherever
you live you will have a profound impact
on the world a cook a cook with the CMU
degree I cannot wait to see how you
change the world
you were my freshman class and therefore
you are my special class of students
forever with whom I have bonded we
through my bondage so much over the past
four years I will always be connected
with you congratulations class of 2017
we will conclude today's ceremony by
singing the alma mater by the vocal
performance class of 2017 we invite you
to please rise and sing along the words
your alma mater can be found in your
program also please remain standing at
the conclusion of the alma mater for the
recession
[Music]
[Applause]
haha
you
[Applause]
[Music]